[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fermetures de plages limitation des
rassemblements des placements restreint
si la france compte 130 foyers de
contamination actifs au coronavirus les
mesures restrictives se multiplient à
travers l'europe face à une possible
résurgence de l'épidémie
bruxelles attaqué en justice par
facebook
la commission européenne enquête
actuellement sur la façon dont le réseau
social utilisent les données
personnelles de ses nombreux
utilisateurs pour générer des revenus
l'entreprise de mark zuckerberg estime
elle que les régulateurs européens
portent atteinte à la vie privée de ses
employés
[Musique]
scènes de violence de plus en plus
fréquentes en irak trois manifestants
sont morts à bagdad après les
mobilisations anti-gouvernementales
d'hier et d'avant-hier protestation
contre l'absence de services publics et
le manque d'électricité en période de
forte chaleur qui et gazière qui
exacerbe les tensions
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous
très heureux de vous retrouver sur arte
france pour un nouveau tour d'horizon de
l'actualité deuxième vague épidémique ou
pas c'est la question sur toutes les
lèvres alors que les experts et le
gouvernement appelle à la vigilance
130 foyers de contamination de cornas
virus sont actuellement actifs en france
selon les autorités sanitaires +7 lors
des dernières 24 heures soit une hausse
de 26% en une semaine
principales régions impacter la nouvelle
aquitaine le grand test et la bretagne
bruno m'égare ban et le chef du service
de service du service de réanimation de
l'hôpital de lariboisière à paris
il appelle à la population à faire
preuve de prudence et à respecter les
gestes barrière depuis une quinzaine de
jours nous assistons à un frémissement
de ce nombre de contaminations qui
valent augmentation notamment avec une
augmentation du taux de reproduction
effectif le fameux airs 0 qui est passé
au delà de 1 dans au moins neuf régions
en france nous nous assistons
effectivement à un retour d'un certain
nombre de patients qui ont été
contaminés par le coronavirus à
l'hôpital alors que à partir de mi mai
et tout au long du mois de juin nous
avions quasiment aucune consultation
pour colette 19
nous avons aujourd'hui aux urgences en
moyenne 1 patients par jour déquilibre
auquel on va pouvoir aboutir pour la
circulation du virus dépend
essentiellement de la qualité du respect
des mesures barrières par l'ensemble de
la population
la crise sanitaire au programme
aujourd'hui d'une conférence de presse
du rassemblement national le rn critique
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif concernant la
gestion de l'épidémie
le parti de marine le pen dévoile son
livre noir du cornât virus intitulé du
fiasco à la bim sa présidente et son
numéro 2 parle de mensonges répétés et
de mauvaises décisions
ils sont au micro de cynthia lauvergeon
le gouvernement est en train de
commettre les mêmes erreurs qu'il ya
plusieurs mois
on laisse encore les frontières ouvertes
on ne prend pas la mesure du risque de
seconde vague on ne teste pas
massivement les français comme on
devrait le faire on ne rembourse pas les
masques qui devrait être gratuit s'ils
sont obligatoires voilà donc tous ces
éléments là font qu'il était urgent que
ce livre noir sortent aujourd'hui pour
que les français prennent conscience que
on n'est pas totalement sortis de cette
séquence est qu'il ya encore des
décisions à prendre aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne sont pas prêts lorsque le
gouvernement bénéficie d'une accalmie
d'une accalmie sanitaire maintenant il
est vrai qu'à des signaux aujourd'hui
qui sont lancés par des médecins par des
spécialistes et qui explique que
l'épidémie aujourd'hui connaît un regain
au moins un regard un regain de
contamination donc de notre devoir aussi
de partis d'opposition qui aspire à
gouverner de prendre un certain nombre
de mesures de précaution et il ya
finalement ce livre noir d'abord une
analyse de ce qui a été mal fait par le
gouvernement des différents mensonges
qui ont été faits infligée au peuple
français mais aussi évidemment des
pistes pour que cela ne se reproduise
par ailleurs en europe l'inquiétude est
de mise notamment de l'autre côté des
pyrénées si paris et berlin
déconseillent de se rendre en catalogne
londres impose des restrictions aux
voyageurs en provenance d'espagne
pourtant madrid réaffirme être un pays
sûr pour les vacanciers théo combes
sauver les meubles
voilà l'objectif du secteur touristique
espagnol alors que la circulation du
virus reprend de manière inquiétante
dans le pays
un domaine d'activité qui pèse pour 12%
du pib espagnol une saison estivale plus
que jamais mal engagée les décisions de
certaines capitales européennes font
craindre le pire à madrid paris avait
déconseillé dès la semaine dernière de
se rendre en catalogne
rejoint par berlin aujourd'hui qui vise
également deux autres régions l'aragon
et la navarre
mais si la décision de londres de
réintroduire des mesures de quarantaine
pour tout voyageur en provenance
d'espagne ce dimanche qui a causé la
colère du premier ministre espagnol
pedro sanchez
je pense que les décisions prises dans
cette affaire par le royaume uni sont
inadaptées car il ya de nombreux
territoires dans notre pays qui ont une
incidence cumulé en termes de
propagation du virus
ce qui est inférieur non seulement la
moyenne européenne non seulement la
moyenne espagnole mais aussi à la
moyenne plus faibles du royaume uni dale
green au mur premier contingent de
visiteurs étrangers avec près de 18
millions de touristes les britanniques
sont une clientèle est essentielle pour
le tourisme espagnol
mais boris johnson reste inflexible sur
sa décision
away the witch week-end nous cherchons
toujours des moyens d'atténuer les
répercussions de la quarantaine à
d'essayer d'aider les gens d'essayer de
nous assurer que la science oeuvre pour
aider les voyageurs et des vacanciers
pour le moment nous devons nous en tenir
aux conseils que nous donnons nous
venons de donner des conseils sur
l'espagne et d'autres endroits dans le
monde
je crains que si nous voyons des signes
d'une deuxième vague dans d'autres pays
elle se sera vraiment notre travail
notre devoir d'agir rapidement et de
manière décisive afin d'arrêter les
nouvelles infections a d'empêcher les
voyageurs de revenir de ces endroits et
de propager la maladie
ici au royaume uni des décisions qui ne
sont pas toujours bien accueilli par les
vacanciers je pense que c'est vraiment
une idée stupide d'imposer une
quatorzaine c'est pourtant un endroit
magnifique je n'ai jamais été dans une
ville où les gens sont si sympathique et
si gentil je pense que tout le monde
devrait venir ici et devrait ignorer ce
que dit le gouvernement britannique
c'est comme une prison d'être là bas on
ne peut rien y faire
je trouve cela très exagéré je pense que
cela s'est bien passé je me sens en
sécurité quand les précautions sont
prises
je me sens en sécurité preuve de
l'inquiétude concernant la fuite des
touristes la région de madrid vient de
décider aujourd'hui de nouvelles mesures
pour tenter de freiner la reprise de
l'épidémie de kovy 19 une urgence
sanitaire mais également économique
selon des chiffres officiels la pandémie
de coronavirus a détruit plus d'un
million d'emplois au deuxième trimestre
en grande majorité dans l'industrie
touristique mais a entraîné une perte de
320 milliards de dollars au secteur
touristique mondiale selon
l'organisation mondiale du tourisme
l europe est particulièrement impacté de
plus en plus de pays du vieux continent
impose de nouvelles restrictions
limitation des rassemblements bulle de
contact réduite port du masque
obligatoire tour d'horizon en images
[Musique]
et
parent
[Musique]
et
la belgique durcit également ces mesures
de restriction parmi les nouvelles
règles couvre-feu dans la région
d'anvers bulle de contact a baissé de 15
à 5 personnes pour les quatre prochaines
semaines
réaction en tant que tel je pense que
c'est la meilleure solution pour le
moment est aussi une des solutions parce
que nous voyons que les infections
viennent des gens de mon âge des gens
qui aiment sortir et boire une bière en
tant que tel c'est très bien mais il ya
toujours des gens qui sont sur le fil du
rasoir et maintenant nous en subissons
les conséquences et nous devons
l'accepter
personnellement je comprends les mesures
il est triste qu'elle n'ait pas été
appliquées plus tôt
ou mieux j'ai pu voir de mes propres
yeux que tout le monde n'avait pas le
bon comportement et même après un
premier avertissement les gens n'étaient
pas prêts à faire un compromis
ici tout le monde aime faire ce qu'il
veut et il est difficile d'aller à
l'encontre de cela on oublie vite s'il
vous plaît ne quittez pas la ville pour
faire la fête ailleurs et aussi dans
l'autre sens nous déconseillons aux gens
de venir dans la région d'anvers
c'est dans l'intérêt de votre propre
santé et de celle de tous ceux qui vous
sont chers et on continue de parler du
coronavirus en belgique avec en direct
dans ce gîte et raphaël blanc d'amour
journalistes à bruxelles
bonsoir rafale blonde amour merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
comment est ce que les belges accueille
ces nouvelles mesures de restriction
évidemment avec beaucoup d'amertume et
de résignation ça fait plaisir à
personne de voir de nouveau essayé de
garder distances avec ce que l'on
apprécié mais il ya aussi une forme de
rigueur et les gens essayent de tanghin
mal de faire respecter la distanciation
social ou même le port du masque ce qui
est relativement bien
c'est en ville au sensible des nouvelles
infections pourtant en france aussi il
ya une circulation accrue du corona
virus la belgique est ce que c'est un
exemple à suivre pour la france ou bien
est-ce que celle inverse aux yeux des
belges c'est difficile à dire puis c'est
difficile je pense de parler au nom de
tous les belges
ce qui est sûr c'est que on a beaucoup
regardé la gestion de la france au début
de la crise et je pense que le fait que
les autorités belges ont fait le pari
entre guillemets de la transparence
c'est-à-dire en faisant des conférences
de presse quotidiennes pour dire le
nombre de patients qui étaient atteints
hospitalisés et les nombres
malheureusement de décès je pense que ça
a payé et rassurer en partie la
population après est-ce que la france ou
la belgique qui est un exemple à cieutat
je ne serai pas bien le ministre fédéral
des affaires étrangères philippe goffin
a dit en parlant de la deuxième vague je
cite on l'imaginait est ce que ça veut
dire que la belgique s'attendait à un
regain de l'épidémie
outre ces nouvelles mesures restrictives
parce que on pourrait s'attendre un
nouveau confinement prochainement
alors oui on s'y attendait ça les
épidémiologistes l'avait annoncé
malheureusement qui oreilles
une deuxième vague alors on savait pas
exactement quand est-ce que ça doit
l'être en septembre en octobre pour
l'instant on a l'impression que ça
commence maintenant
après votre question c'est est pardon la
question était de savoir s'il y avait
possiblement 1re confinement qui était à
l'étude du côté de la belgique et des
autorités belges
pour l'instant c'est pas annoncés tels
quels
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on a reconfirmé
socialement c'est à dire qu'on a réduit
la pub avec les personnes avec
lesquelles on a contacts mais pour
l'instant c'est pas à leur 1re
confinement malgré qu a rouvert ce qui
est la ville où il ya le plus qui
concentre le plus de nouveaux 4019 des
questions se posent sur ce qu'on doit
confiné cette ville en particulier
quelqu'un il ya un couvre-feu à anvers
alors pas aujourd'hui pour des questions
juridiques ça n'a pas été encore mis en
place à devrait être mis en place à
partir de demain donc à couvre fait
qu'il devrait commencer de 23h jusqu'à 6
heures du matin donc une des craintes en
fait c'est que les bars à la fermeture
des bars les gens continuent à faire la
traite mais juste en changeant de
province deux villes et a il ya un petit
peu plus loin et propagent le virus par
la même occasion il ya également cette
mesure concernant les bulles de
contacter un c'est un terme que vous
utilisez chez vous du côté de de la
belgique
on passe de 15 à 5 personnes est ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus alors en
fait on est passé de la bulle social
c'est là le nombre de personnes avec
lesquelles vous pouvez faire des
activités boire un verre aller au
restaurant et c'est à partir en vacances
et avant c'était 15
on pouvait on avait le droit d'aller
voir 15 personnes par par personne
maintenant on passe de cinq personnes a
par foyer donc ce qu'il vous dira que
désormais si vous voulez aller voir aux
amis et bien vous allez faire le devoir
le faire le choix est limité
dernière question philippe goffin a
indiqué la belgique était au coeur de
l'europe aujourd'hui que pensent les
belges de
ouverture des frontières alors elle a eu
lieu il ya quelques semaines et pour
être allé en reportage aux frontières
franco à la frontière franco belge
c'était quelque chose qu'on attendait
avec impatience notamment de la part des
commerces mais aussi des familles qui
est parfois se retrouver dans des
situations où l'une était en belgique et
l'autre en france et ne pouvait pas se
voir merci à raphaël blonde avant
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journalistes à
bruxelles
facebook dans le viseur de la commission
européenne le réseau social fait l'objet
d'un examen minutieux de la concurrence
de l'union européenne sur d'éventuelles
pratiques anticoncurrentielles
d'après les chiffres de la commission et
d'integrity watch les gars femmes
dépenserait plus de 22 millions d'euros
lobbying auprès de bruxelles à plus de 8
millions d'euros dépensés par google et
moins de 5 et la part facebook
l'entreprise de mark zuckerberg gars qui
a de son côté porté plainte contre la
commission européenne pour des pratiques
qu'elle juge trop intrusive dans ses
enquêtes
nadège abderrazak facebook porte plainte
pour atteinte à la vie privée et non ce
n'est pas une blague
le réseau social américain a fait appel
à la cour de justice de l'union
européenne parce qu'il estime que la
commission lui pose des questions trop
intrusive bruxelles enquête en effet sur
la manière dont facebook collecte et
tire profit des données personnelles de
ses utilisateurs
elle veut aussi savoir si sa place de
marché en ligne d avantage ou non ses
concurrents le géant du numérique a déjà
fourni 315 mille documents depuis le
début des investigations en mars
mais aujourd'hui visiblement c'en est
trop
la nature exceptionnellement vaste des
requêtes de la commission signifie que
nous devrions leur fournir des documents
principalement sans rapport avec leur
enquête
on demande des informations personnelles
hautement sensibles comme des
informations médicales ou financières et
des informations privées sur les
familles des employés
réponse 2
union européenne les informations
collectées sont conformes à une enquête
normale sur la toile cette plainte
déposée par facebook provoque déjà les
moqueries des internautes
il est plus que gonfler ce type lui qui
viole allègrement la vie privée utilise
des données personnelles en les
extorquant de millions voire de
milliards d'individus se plaint d'un
traitement lié à une enquête légitime
c'est vrai que facebook est
irréprochable au niveau protection des
données
oui oui facebook porte plainte contre
bruxelles pour atteinte à la vie privée
de la part de facebook qui vous siphonne
vos données personnelles
trop fort alors oui ce le fait que
facebook poursuivent qui que ce soit
pour atteinte à la vie privée peut
laisser sans voix
on le sait la société de mark zuckerberg
engrange des milliards de dollars de
profits avec les données de ses
utilisateurs est elle appelée d'une fois
nagé en eau trouble en 2018 facebook a
été mise en cause pour avoir dépêché un
médecin dans de grands hôpitaux
américains pour les convaincre de
partager les dossiers médicaux de leurs
patients au cours de cette même année on
a appris que la société analysait les
messages de ses utilisateurs et que dans
certains cas elle a même fouillé dans
les discussions pour supprimer des
messages dans lesquels ses dirigeants
étaient mentionnés des rumeurs et bien
d'autres allégations qui avait été
confirmé à la suite du scandale
cambridge analytica début 2018
rappelez vous cette société privée
utiliser une application tierce pour
récolter les données personnelles de 87
millions d'utilisateurs de facebook
elles ont ensuite été vendu à
différentes entreprises et elle aurait
même permis d'influencer les résultats
de l'élection présidentielle américaine
de 2000 16 en faveur de donald trump
elle les problèmes ne font que
s'accumuler pour mark zuckerberg
une cinquantaine d'états américains
enquêtent en effet sur les pratiques de
facebook en plus des deux enquêtes déjà
ouverte par le département américain de
la justice et la commission fédérale du
commerce
cette enquête se concentre sur la
domination de facebook dans le secteur
des réseaux sociaux et la conduite
potentiellement anti concurrentiels qui
en résulte à mesure que nous
poursuivrons notre enquête nous
utiliserons tous les outils
d'investigation à notre disposition pour
déterminer si les actions de facebook
ont étouffé la concurrence et mis les
utilisateurs en danger ce mercredi les
pdg des gaffes à doivent être entendus
par la commission des affaires
judiciaires de la chambre des
représentants américaine mark zuckerberg
jfb sauce tim cook sundar pichai shy
tous les quatre vont devoir répondre à
des questions qui portent sur
d'éventuels abus de position dominante
vous voyez la poésie la position sur ce
sujet de philippe rouzaud et les
bâtonniers d'aix en provence et avocats
en droit des affaires
à mon sens à partir du moment où on est
sur le terrain des pratiques anti trust
il est évident que la commission
européenne va pousser je pense à son
paroxysme blanquette et puis vous savez
que derrière tout ça c'est une histoire
de gros sous
facebook notamment mais amazon google et
les autres s'affranchissent des droits à
payer en conséquence
c'est également l'arroseur arrosé dans
un premier temps c'est à dire que les
communautés vont pousser je pense au
maximum et alors paroxysme les enquêtes
pour essayer de faire tomber les grandes
pour que ceci bien évidemment règle les
impôts pour lesquels justement ils
s'affranchissent ans en partant dans
d'autres pays qui ne sont pas assujettis
et zoomer
un manifestant est décédé ce matin à
bagdad des suites de ses blessures il
est le troisième a trouvé la mort en
marge des contestations d'hier et
d'avant-hier en irak mobilisation de
plusieurs centaines de personnes pour
dénoncer l'absence de services publics
et le manque d'électricité et ce dans un
contexte de très forte chaleur qui
exacerbe les tensions font soit 10 buts
il y a fool sur les rives du tigre pour
tenter de se rafraîchir avec des
températures dépassant parfois les 55
degrés la chaleur est difficilement
supportable pour les habitants de la
capitale irakienne
déjà éprouvée par la pandémie de
couronnes à virus mais le plus difficile
pour les bagdadiens c'est le manque
d'électricité
[Musique]
la température affecte l'état
psychologique pour nous les citoyens
ordinaires
on peut pas supporter ces températures
élevées si le gouvernement met de
l'électricité à disposition nous nous
sentirons soulagé et travailleront dans
de bonnes conditions
mais là nous ne pouvons pas vivre
correctement et nous nous demandons
comment faire pour que le gouvernement
rend l'électricité disponible nous rend
à l'aise pour arriver à travailler
correctement avec l'électricité
disponible
nous sommes tous dehors
nous sommes tous en sueur si
l'électricité et est disponible nous
resterions à la maison en profitant de
la fraîcheur mais c'est un rêve
l'électricité est le pilier de la vie
l'électricité est essentiel au travail
tout comme les hôpitaux
la vie est brisée son aile après des
années de négligence le réseau public
irakien n'est pas capable de fournir
plus de quelques heures d'électricité
par jour
obligeant les irakiens se débrouiller
avec des générateurs proposé par des
entrepreneurs privés depuis la chute de
saddam hussein en 2003 aucun ministre de
l'électricité n'a été capable de
terminer son mandat
tous ont démissionné ou ont été limogés
pour satisfaire la rue une rue qui
encore gronder ce week end à bagdad
deux manifestants ont été tués après des
tirs de grenades lacrymogènes de
policiers place tahrir les premiers
morts de la contestation sous le nouveau
gouvernement irakien accusées de
reproduire les violences de son
prédécesseur le premier ministre irakien
moustaph al-qasimi ordonne une enquête
sur la mort des deux manifestants
les jeunes qui manifestaient exercer un
droit légitime et les forces de sécurité
n'avaient aucune autorisation pour tirer
ne serait ce qu'une seule balle en
direction de nos frères les manifestants
or quoi tana tarp et a été ouverte sur
ce qu'il s'est passé place tahrir et
j'ai demandé à voir les résultats sous
72 heures en mai dernier lors de sa
prise de pouvoir le nouveau premier
ministre était d'ailleurs déjà engagé à
faire la lumière sur les centaines de
morts au cours des derniers mois de
manifestations des manifestations
déclenchées en octobre 2019 pour
dénoncer la corruption réclamer des
emplois des services fonctionnels ayant
fait plus de 550 morts et des dizaines
de milliers de blessés dans tout le pays
même si le mouvement a perdu de son
ardeur quelques dizaines de
protestataires continuent d'occuper les
tentes place tahrir pour aller là-bas
kahone de l'institut de recherches et
d'études méditerranée moyen-orient les
habitants de bassorah souffre à la fois
de chaleur et du courant navire à ce
jour là les températures arrive à 55
degrés et les basses ravi n'ont que deux
ou trois heures d'électricité
alors il est totalement désarmé par
rapport aux convives disney totalement
désarmé par rapport aux milices
totalement désarmé par rapport aux
torrents forces de l'organisation d'
états islamiques totalement désarmés
face au désengagement des états unis
d'amérique
il est hors n'est vraiment dans
l'impasse totale l'état irakien de 2003
à 2020 a été refondée reconstruit sur
deux principes a peut-être vous serez
étonné mais malheureusement c'est la
réalité le premier principe c'est ce que
j'appelle dans mon livre l'impossible
est à grayan la milice isation de la
société irakienne
le deuxième pilier ou le deuxième
principe de sur lequel l état irakien a
été refondée c'est la systématisation de
la corruption
aujourd'hui attaqué à la correction
s'est attaqué au système 15 mai lui-même
est un enfant légitime de ce système
l'opposition fortement désiré la
sémantique est signé
vous si c'est le premier ministre malien
appelle ses opposants à intégrer le
prochain gouvernement d'union nationale
refus de ces derniers malgré la
recommandation ce sens de la cédéao le
chef du gouvernement qui est reconduit
dans ses fonctions par le président
ibrahim boubacar keita ibk a fortement
contesté depuis joie
je voudrais en profiter pour lancer un
appel un appel sincère à nos soeurs et à
nos frères du m51 rfp et d'autres
regroupements pour qu'ils entrent dans
ce gouvernement
j'aimerais dire qu'ils sont attendus et
même fortement désiré en ce prochain
attelage gouvernemental qui doit être
mise en place incessamment
c'est la fin de cette édition prochain
point sur l'actualité dans 30 minutes
à tout à l'heure resté sur arte france
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité
[Musique]